humor me remind me what topic are we in
again integration but this question has
three parts to it and integration is
only the last part there are three
things in total and two of them come
before integration actually starts so
you're probably thinking about this
hopefully in an informal way because
I've given you enough information to
know how to do a question like this but
let's try and give you a bit of
structure around this so that you have a
bit of a pattern in your head so your
brain can go to it quickly what are the
two things you're going to need before
you even get to integration before you
can write that beloved squiggly integral
sign there are at least two things you
need to know anyone want to throw in a
suggestion yeah I need points of
intersection I need to know where these
two things meet because when I make this
integral sign I need a lower boundary
and I need an upper boundary and finding
those is its own thing
it's its own problem right so the first
thing that I would do is I would find
out the intersections okay why don't we
do that and then we'll work out what
this second piece is and maybe by the
time we've worked at the intersections
you have worked out what the middle
piece is okay how do I find points of
intersection I'm going to solve
simultaneously yeah so you can see how
it's been written I've got Y as the
subject in this one here so I might as
well just take that substitute directly
into here okay I'm going to get this X
plus 2 X plus 6 yes happy times now I've
got this pesky square root hanging
around in there so it's very hard to
work with but that's okay if I square
both sides I'm going to get just a
quadratic that's easy to deal with
okay now pay close attention let me show
you the most common error that happens
when students square both sides the
right-hand sides not too dramatic that's
doubled that's squared right and the
most common thing and you'll laugh
because I'm pointing it out and make it
really obvious and you've got a friend
next to you saying oh of course don't do
this but the number of people who do
this in an exam when there's not someone
next to them and no one's drawing
attention to it
is really sad so this is the most common
error okay what have I done I forgot to
square the five now there's a good
reason why your brain does that because
it's concentrating on the thing you're
trying to get rid of and you're
concentrating on that square root okay
but it's so easy to forget and it still
looks like a quadratic and you can still
depending on what kind of numbers you
have you can still solve it and get
numbers out and put them faithfully into
your boundaries it only starts to fall
apart when you're like why my numbers so
messy right so just watch out this comes
up in other places like lockers if you
remember that from last year you often
had to square both sides because you'd
have like a distance equation so just
watch out when there's two things there
okay
now this pan here I'm not especially
interested in because you know how to
handle this problem this is not
challenging you're gonna end up with a
factorized quadratic has anyone already
got it I think it starts with an X plus
one and then there's a X minus 14 right
so I've landed on this quadratic
equation it's factorized because you can
expand everything collect like terms
which gives you two solutions now we're
at a junction point what do I do what
are these two values what do they even
mean these are the what was I looking
for these are the points of intersection
right so these two values are going to
become my upper and lower boundary so
I'll just store that away I can write
the integral off from negative 1 to 14
but what do I actually put in the
integrand what is going to come next and
this is where this second thing comes in
hmm it's between right it's between this
and this think back to yesterday when we
were working out areas between curves
what did I do with the two functions how
did I combine them I took the difference
which is to subtract right now hold on a
second
squared X plus 2 and then this guy over
here which is written in some awkward
form let's write in a slightly less
awkward form I can take the difference
between these two in
two ways right I can subtract one from
the other or I could do it in the
reverse order so how do I work out which
one comes first okay I need a picture of
some kind right it doesn't have to be
beautiful but it has to be good enough
that I can work out what's going on so I
would say
orna or if you want you could say
position because that's actually the
thing you're going to be looking for
which tells you your order okay so I
hope you have a rough sketch square root
of x plus 2 hmm let's think for a second
square root of x that's a simpler
version so you have an image in your
mind for what the square root of x looks
like what did what effect is that + to
you what does it do it shifts a which
way it goes to the left it goes
backwards right so here's my value
negative 2 because you told me to go
that far right now this is a quick and
dirty graph but it's actually going to
be useful to me to know what that
y-intercept is can you work out what it
is it should be root 2 right to find a
way intercept you would let x equals 0 y
equals the square root of 0 plus 2 now
I'm gonna do something slightly unusual
and I wonder if you can tick over in
your brain why I do this I'm not going
to write the square root of 2 I'm going
to write what I know the square root of
2 is roughly equal to that 1.4 ok now
you're like well how did you know that
well you will know that - we can do the
square root of 2 on your calculator
enough times and it's a very common
number now why on earth would I go and
write it as an approximate decimal when
I have such an easy exact way of writing
it what's the purpose of this picture
again what is that what is the intent
behind this I'm trying to solve this
problem right I want to know where the
graphs are in relation to each other
okay so the precision of this number is
only important in so much as it helps me
work out where these two things are so
remember how I wrote it like this right
what's the y-intercept of this thing
it's a fraction right now but that's
hard to work with
I'd much rather write it as a decimal
this is one of the best things about
decimals you can compare every number on
the real
the line and don't have to worry about
denominators and we don't things it's
one point two right so where's one point
two you just just a smidge below like
there maybe okay
gradient if this light is going to be a
fear so super shallow right so I'm going
to draw something like this now this
scale is pretty horrendous but it does
matter because I just have my rough
picture and now I know where the area is
you can see how bad my scale is they
just have to forgive me for that but
it's said its purpose hasn't it I can
easily determine order and position from
this because I can clearly see in this
little spot what's above what does that
make sense